well brian that massive fire overnight
in the southwest valley we brought it to
you live on facebook after our newscast
at 11 dozens of firefighters working to
put out the flames here
viewers sending us videos of an
apartment complex which was under
construction
but it just burnt to the ground and i
mean these images really speak for
themselves this is a very busy
residential area
and you can see just how close the fire
was to all of these surrounding homes
and businesses
and then this morning the aftermath of
this massive fire can be seen in drone
video this is by nevada aerial media
taking these images
at the apartment structure you can see
it's just ashes now
millions of dollars in damage and
tonight authorities still are trying to
figure out exactly how this one started
so as firefighters are now working to
try and get that fire under control
many people were evacuated from some of
those nearby neighborhoods
eight news now reporter kate houston is
live tonight here at five o'clock from
the construction area near fort apache
and tropicana which investigators are
now calling
a total loss kate
yes that's right where we're standing
right here you can see
just how much damage this fire caused
witnesses tell us that this complex was
nearly done
now all that remains is charred wood and
metal toppled over each other
while this fire was raging neighbors
were evacuating
worried their homes may be next i
remember people crying and
screaming and shouting in the middle of
the night neighbors woke to a massive
fire burning
close to their home immediately when we
opened the door when metro had banged on
the door
we could smell the smoke and we could
see that it was like getting hazy
and i thought that our building was on
fire joey and sharon codora live in an
apartment just down the street from
where the fire started
when i came out here that's when i got
really worried because the wind was
blowing
and it looked like it was coming over
here so i definitely thought
at that instant that it we were going to
get it as well joey is an army veteran
and former cop
when he realized what was happening he
sprang into action
going door to door making sure neighbors
were evacuated to safety
i tried to get as many people as i could
out of the building that was my main
concern
i didn't even grab my documents she had
already grabbed everything
like i said my main concern was helping
elders the kedoras had an emergency go
bag already packed with important
documents and items
which helped them get out quickly as
they left the complex they described
seeing large embers flying into nearby
trees and bushes
even hitting their car back and forth
people without shoes because
they had no clue they weren't prepared
they just wanted to get out
now thankfully nobody was injured in
this fire
throughout the day fire crews were on
scene putting out any potential hot
spots and assessing
some of the damage that is here we are
still waiting to see what the cause of
this fire was
reporting live from tropicana and fort
apache kate houston 8 news now